Let's think about what
functions really do, and then
we'll think about the idea of
an inverse of a function.
So let's start with a pretty
straightforward function.
Let's say f of x is
equal to 2x plus 4.
And so if I take f of 2, f of 2
is going to be equal to 2 times
2 plus 4, which is 4
plus 4, which is 8.
I could take f of 3, which
is 2 times 3 plus 4,
which is equal to 10.
6 plus 4.
So let's think about it
in a little bit more
of an abstract sense.
So there's a set of things that
I can input into this function.
You might already be
familiar with that notion.
It's the domain.
The set of all of the things
that I can input into that
function, that is the domain.
And in that domain, 2 is
sitting there, you have 3 over
there, pretty much you could
input any real number
into this function.
So this is going to be all
real, but we're making it a
nice contained set here just
to help you visualize it.
Now, when you apply the
function, let's think about
it means to take f of 2.
We're inputting a number, 2,
and then the function is
outputting the number 8.
It is mapping us from 2 to 8.
So let's make another set here
of all of the possible values
that my function can take on.
And we can call that the range.
There are more formal ways to
talk about this, and there's a
much more rigorous discussion
of this later on, especially in
the linear algebra playlist,
but this is all the different
values I can take on.
So if I take the number 2 from
our domain, I input it into the
function, we're getting
mapped to the number 8.
So let's let me draw that out.
So we're going from 2 to
the number 8 right there.
And it's being done
by the function.
The function is
doing that mapping.
That function is mapping
us from 2 to 8.
This right here, that
is equal to f of 2.
Same idea.
You start with 3, 3 is being
mapped by the function to 10.
It's creating an association.
The function is mapping
us from 3 to 10.
Now, this raises an
interesting question.
Is there a way to get back from
8 to the 2, or is there a
way to go back from
the 10 to the 3?
Or is there some
other function?
Is there some other function,
we can call that the inverse
of f, that'll take us back?
Is there some other
function that'll take
us from 10 back to 3?
We'll call that the inverse
of f, and we'll use that as
notation, and it'll take
us back from 10 to 3.
Is there a way to do that?
Will that same inverse of f,
will it take us back from--
if we apply 8 to it-- will
that take us back to 2?
Now, all this seems very
abstract and difficult.
What you'll find is it's
actually very easy to solve for
this inverse of f, and I think
once we solve for it, it'll
make it clear what
I'm talking about.
That the function takes you
from 2 to 8, the inverse will
take us back from 8 to 2.
So to think about that, let's
just define-- let's just
say y is equal to f of x.
So y is equal to f of x,
is equal to 2x plus 4.
So I can write just y is equal
to 2x plus 4, and this once
again, this is our function.
You give me an x,
it'll give me a y.
But we want to go the
other way around.
We want to give you
a y and get an x.
So all we have to do is
solve for x in terms of y.
So let's do that.
If we subtract 4 from both
sides of this equation-- let me
switch colors-- if we subtract
4 from both sides of this
equation, we get y minus 4 is
equal to 2x, and then if we
divide both sides of this
equation by 2, we get y over 2
minus 2-- 4 divided by 2
is 2-- is equal to x.
Or if we just want to write it
that way, we can just swap the
sides, we get x is equal to
1/2y-- same thing as
y over 2-- minus 2.
So what we have here is
a function of y that
gives us an x, which is
exactly what we wanted.
We want a function of these
values that map back to an x.
So we can call this-- we could
say that this is equal to--
I'll do it in the same color--
this is equal to f inverse
as a function of y.
Or let me just write it
a little bit cleaner.
We could say f inverse as a
function of y-- so we can have
10 or 8-- so now the range is
now the domain for f inverse.
f inverse as a function of y
is equal to 1/2y minus 2.
So all we did is we started
with our original function, y
is equal to 2x plus 4, we
solved for-- over here, we've
solved for y in terms of x--
then we just do a little bit of
algebra, solve for x in terms
of y, and we say that that is
our inverse as a function of y.
Which is right over here.
And then, if we, you know, you
can say this is-- you could
replace the y with an a, a b,
an x, whatever you want to do,
so then we can just
rename the y as x.
So if you put an x into this
function, you would get f
inverse of x is equal
to 1/2x minus 2.
So all you do, you solve for x,
and then you swap the y and the
x, if you want to
do it that way.
That's the easiest way
to think about it.
And one thing I want to point
out is what happens when you
graph the function
and the inverse.
So let me just do a
little quick and dirty
graph right here.
And then I'll do a bunch of
examples of actually solving
for inverses, but I really
just wanted to give
you the general idea.
Function takes you from the
domain to the range, the
inverse will take you from that
point back to the original
value, if it exists.
So if I were to graph these--
just let me draw a little
coordinate axis right here,
draw a little bit of a
coordinate axis right there.
This first function, 2x plus 4,
its y intercept is going to be
1, 2, 3, 4, just like that, and
then its slope will
look like this.
It has a slope of 2, so it will
look something like-- its graph
will look-- let me make it a
little bit neater than that--
it'll look something like that.
That's what that
function looks like.
What does this
function look like?
What does the inverse function
look like, as a function of x?
Remember we solved for x,
and then we swapped the x
and the y, essentially.
We could say now that y is
equal to f inverse of x.
So we have a y-intercept
of negative 2, 1, 2, and
now the slope is 1/2.
The slope looks like this.
Let me see if I can draw it.
The slope looks-- or the line
looks something like that.
And what's the
relationship here?
I mean, you know, these look
kind of related, it looks
like they're reflected
about something.
It'll be a little bit more
clear what they're reflected
about if we draw the
line y is equal to x.
So the line y equals
x looks like that.
I'll do it as a dotted line.
And you could see, you have
the function and its inverse,
they're reflected about
the line y is equal to x.
And hopefully, that
makes sense here.
Because over here, on
this line, let's take
an easy example.
Our function, when you take
0-- so f of 0 is equal to 4.
Our function is mapping 0 to 4.
The inverse function, if
you take f inverse of 4, f
inverse of 4 is equal to 0.
Or the inverse function is
mapping us from 4 to 0.
Which is exactly
what we expected.
The function takes us from the
x to the y world, and then we
swap it, we were swapping
the x and the y.
We would take the inverse.
And that's why it's reflected
around y equals x.
So this example that I just
showed you right here, function
takes you from 0 to 4-- maybe I
should do that in the function
color-- so the function takes
you from 0 to 4, that's the
function f of 0 is 4, you see
that right there, so it goes
from 0 to 4, and then
the inverse takes us
back from 4 to 0.
So f inverse takes us
You saw that right there.
When you evaluate 4 here,
1/2 times 4 minus 2 is 0.
The next couple of videos we'll
do a bunch of examples so you
really understand how to solve
these and are able to do
the exercises on our
application for this.